وصول رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورج ملوني
للسلطه قد يكون نموذجا يحتذى به لجناح في
الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي في الانتخابات
النصفيه صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت ان ميلوني
برزت كنقطه مرجعيه للجمهوريين المؤيدين
لدونالد ترامب والذين فسروا صعودها على
انه تاكيد على قيمهم وعلى اهدافهم يرى هذا
الجناح في الحزب الجمهوري ان جورج ميلوني
تتحدث بوضوح عن معتقداتها ولم تتنازل في
وجه اليسار وتغلبت على ما وصفوها جميعا
بوسائل الاعلام الفاسيه والعنصريه نتذكر
انه فور اعلان نتائج الانتخابات الايطاليه
انتشر على نطاق واسع مقطع من خطاب لميلوني
تنتقد فيه ما قالت انه هجوم مستمر على
الاسره ودين تنفذه قوه تسعى لعالم يختفي
فيه اشكال الهويه على حد قولها وحظي
المقطع المصور حينها بتداول واسع بين ابرز
الشخصيات الجمهوريه الامريكيه
[تصفيق]
واشنطن بوست قالت ان صعوضه ميلوني ونجاحها
في حكم ايطاليا يمهد الطريق الى السلطه
لشخصيات اخرى كانت ذات يوم هامشيه في
اوروبا ميلوني من جانبها عملت لسنوات من
اجل بناء علاقات مع الحزب الجمهوري
الامريكي وتحدثت في فبراير الماضي في
مؤتمر للحزب في وقت لاحق وخلال مقابله مع
واشنطن بوست تجاهلت المرشحه جورج ميلوني
سؤالا حول ما اذا كانت تشعر بانها اكثر
حجازا لجناح ترامب او الذين يعرضون سطوته
للجيولوجيه على الحزب اضافه الصحيفه ان
ميلون اشتهرت في الولايات المتحده لان
خطابها في بعض النواحي يماثل خطاب دونالد
ترامب بستنادها الى فكره الطبقه الوسطى
المنسيه التي تحتقرها النخب بينما تصور
نفسها على انها مدافعه عن المستضعفين
لذلك افترض بعض الامريكيين من اليمين ان
فوزها يدل على تمرد شعبي مناهض للنظام
الحاكم او ما قد يطلق عليه الشعب في
مواجهه السلطه تبقى احدى اكبر نقاط نقاش
في الولايات المتحده تلك المتعلقه بجذور
حزب اخوه ايطاليا الذي تم انشائه قبل عقد
من الزمن وينحدر من مجموعه سابقه اسسها
متعاطفون مع موسوليني بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
في هذا الصدد اشار محللون لتجاهل الحكومه
الايطاليه مسيره لالاف الايطاليين مؤخرا
برموز فاشيه في بريدابيو مسقط راس
موسوليني احيانا لمئويه دخول الزعيم
الفاسي للعاصمه روما
اذا كانت ميلوني كما ذكرنا وجها نسائيا
ايطاليه مؤثرا في الانتخابات الامريكيه
النصفيه لكن كيف ستصوت نساء الامريكيات في
انتخاب التجديد النصفي الحقيقه ان قوه هذا
الصوت ستكون حاسمه وقد تحدد نتيجه
الانتخابات بحسب تحليلا لمعهد بروكينغ
المعهد واشعار الى ان الاصوات النسائيه
غالبا ما كانت من نصيب الحزب الديمقراطي
خلال السنوات الماضيه مرجحا ان تشكل
اصواتهم دعما لجهود ديمقراطيين اعتمد
التحليل على اجراء محاكاه اظهرت زياده في
اقدام النساء وهو مثلاعكس ايجابيا على
المرشحين الديمقراطيين
ارجع هذا التحليل زياده نسبه المشاركه الى
الجدل حول قوانين الاجهاض
اكد الامر ايضا استطلاع اجرته مجله
ايكونوميست ويوجاف اواخر اكتوبر
ظهر ان 60% من النساء من المشاركات في
الاستطلاع
سيصوتن بسبب قضيه الاجهاض نفسها كشف
الاستطلاع ان واحدا 51% من النساء
المشاركات اخترنا مرشحا ديمقراطيا في
الانتخابات النصفيه المقبله مقابله 46%
اخترنا مرشحا جمهوريا
[موسيقى]